ah je parle du thread d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'ai compris ça vous plaît
un peu moins laisserait deux tours des
chaînes youtube étrange parce que c'est
toute une clique c'est du fun alors que
laisserait twitter on sait pas trop
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un thread
espagnol que lauren lucioles la tête ici
de lucioles a traduit pour nous et
maintenant je compte jusqu'à 3 et
françois m'ont dit merci lorraine 1 2 3
merci lens-rennes chaire est superbe
vous allez voir il ya un peu de deux
sortes d'énigmes à résoudre un petit peu
comme le thread avec le message vocal à
l'époque est un petit peu des trucs
comme ça et du coup je pense à vraiment
vous permet en tout cas ça fait
longtemps que j'avais pas kiffer devant
un thread comme devant suis là alors on
y va
tout commence le 20 août 2018 lorsque
neil à garcia dit avoir trouvé un
téléphone
elle pensait d'abord qu'il appartenait à
la fille qu'on voit sur la page
d'accueil du téléphone mais en fait non
cette fille est morte
aux etats unis huit ans avant alors
qu'est-ce que son téléphone fait là ça
commence ay bien elle nous précise
qu'elle a trouvé ce téléphone en
rentrant chez elle à madrid dans un parc
comme n'y avait pas de mot de passe
n'est là elle commence à fouiller dans
le téléphone pour trouver des numéros
des pistes en fait mais la première
douche froide
aucun contact enregistré dans le
téléphone comme s'ils étaient neuf mais
il est pas neuve puisqu'il ya la photo
de cette meuf là en page d'accueil
bizarre en fouillant n'est là tout ce
qu'elle trouve c'est un compte facebook
et un compte instagram et c'est comme ça
qu'elle est remontée jusqu'à la
potentielle propriétaire du téléphone
j'ai fait les guillemets comme un gros
connard facebook et un stade sur
lesquels il ya quelqu'un qui était
loguer quelqu'un qui répondait au nom
deux n'ont pas bella mais marta beauty
alès le contenu de ce compte installer
un peu flou parce qu'il ya très très peu
de photos d'elle c'est assez impersonnel
c'est surtout des photos de paysages et
de bâtiments avec aucune légende et
aucun commentaire et en plus elle suit
personne et personne ne la suit non plus
que c'est vraiment chaud loup comme
compte instants alors qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire de plus quand on en est là
sans faire de jeu de mots parce qu'il
s'appelle exprès je ne partage pas de
quoi être fier je devrais avoir honte
on oublie les jeux de mots de mère
d'élève avoir vraiment une bonne idée
elle va faire une recherche d'image
google à partir de la photo de profil
facebook de martin née la tombe alors
sur un blog dont la photo de profil
aient la même photo de profil que le
facebook de marta sauf que choses très
bizarres l'auteur du blog c'est pas du
tout martens et béatrice williams
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde le
blog date de 2008 et c'est que des
photos d'une étudiante américaine en
voyage en espagne et les photos sont
exactement les mêmes que celles sur le
facebook de martin on en vient donc à la
conclusion que martha n'existe pas et
que c'est juste quelqu'un qui a créé ce
compte et qui utilise toutes les photos
du bleu
de béatrice williams n'est là va trouver
le mail de béatrice dans la bio de son
blog elle va lui envoyer un mail pour la
prévenir que quelqu'un usurpé son
identité et vol toutes ces photos pour
les mettre sur un faux compte facebook
les réponses au nom de martha che bella
dans la tête ça influence mais c'est pas
béatrice qui a répondu à ce mail mais
c'est son père et son père apprend année
là que béatrice est morte il y a huit
ans il avait déjà vu est signalé
quelques comptes qui usurpé l'identité
de sa fille et demande année là de faire
de même pour que ces comptes soient
clôturés ça veut donc dire que le
téléphone que naît la trouver il
n'appartient pas à béatrice mais il
appartient à martha même s'il ya une
photo de béatrice en fond d'écran n'est
là elle veut donc retrouver cette
fameuse marta est aussi peut-être
comprendre pourquoi elle a usurpé
l'identité de béatrice je loue quand
même mené là va checker dans le journal
des appels si elle a émis ou reçu des
appels d'un numéro est là uniquement
émis des appels envers un numéro mais
beaucoup d'appels en toute logique elle
va donc appelé ce même numéro pour
essayer de retrouver la trace de martha
la propriétaire du téléphone et elle va
tomber sur un truc parfaitement chou
c'est quoi ces sauts ses sauts dans la
vraie vie un autre truc bizarre mart
avait aussi reçu plein de sms de ce
numéro qui étaient des séries de
chiffres et de lettres incompréhensible
on pense donc que le tel appartenant à
un escroc qui jouait à un jeu un jeu
peut-être un peu dangereux ou flippant
ou illégal et que pour pas se faire
choper par les autorités il a usurpé
l'identité de beatriz qui est décédée
comme ça il risquait rien s'il
téléphonez retrouvez aussi les appels
sont tracés ou quoi ou alors peut-être
que c'était simplement à quelqu'un qui
jouait à une sorte de jeu vous savez
comme ce jeu de merde là le blue eyes
challenge ou le mode challenge qui sont
des trucs mais nul à chier c'est
horrible ne fait jamais ça c'est pourri
ces sortes de jeux ou en gros il ya
quelqu'un qui va dire fais ci fais ça
fais ci fais ça puis ensuite il va te
voler des données personnelles va te
mettre vraiment en danger et va [ __ ]
ta santé mentale et sa fille ni même des
fois par des suicides alors voilà petit
message d'avertissement en passant dans
ce thread ne jouez jamais à ces jeux
c'est débile futile ça sert à rien et
les gens qui sont derrière ces jo la
soupe démoniaque ce téléphone
appartenait donc sûrement à quelqu'un
qui jouait à l'un de ces jeux malsains à
un nouveau jeu peut être alors est ce
que la personne à qui appartient le
téléphone à juge de téléphone et arrêter
de jouer parce qu'elle a pris peur ou
alors est ce que cette personne c'est
fait
amy n'est pas ce qu'elle a vu un truc
qu'il faut pas elle a fait un truc il
faut pas dans le jeu et ça dérape et on
sait pas il nous reste donc comme
élément juste les séquences de lettres
et chiffres que le téléphone avait reçu
par message et y en a au total 12 vous
savez très bien à quoi ça correspond on
a habitué des coordonnées gps bien sûr
quelqu'un va alors placés chaque repères
sur une map et envoyer le screen année
là et ça donne un truc un peu abstrait
en tout cas tous les points correspondre
à des endroits à madrid n'est lave
ensuite faire une découverte très
intéressante elle remarque que chaque
fin de série est constitué d'une date
d'une heure et d'une orientation n'est
là va alors prendre l'une de ces
séquences et tester sa théorie en
mettant les coordonnées sur google
street et en orientant la caméra dans la
direction indiquée en l'occurrence l'ès
est bonne on obtient une photo du même
point de vue une photo qui se trouve sur
le compte instagram de martin
coïncidence non elle va tester avec tous
les sms et chaque sms reçus correspond
en fait à une photo d'eux un star c'est
mieux c'est évident les photos de ce
compte instagram sont des photos qui ne
se trouve pas sous le bloc de batteries
ce william
donc on suppose que c'est des photos
qu'on vraiment été prise par la personne
qui avait ce téléphone l'enregistrement
parler de 12 épreuves
on en est à 11 photos alors née là
qu'est ce qu'elle va faire elle va s'en
charger la dernière photo doit donc être
prise le 21 août à 23h47 aux coordonnées
indiquées par le sms
elle va taper les coordonnées sur google
street et on tombe sur un parc bien que
des armes comme dans n'importe quel parc
va alors pourquoi il ya une heure
précise pour prendre ses photos c'est
chelou elle va alors compter ce qu'il
est possible de compter sur chaque photo
qui assurent le compte instagram par
exemple sur une photo il ya une main on
peut y compter cinq doigts sur une autre
photo ya des tours et on peut en compter
quatre parfois sur des photos il ya même
directement marquer un chiffre par
exemple sur scène où il a marqué 81
bref qu'on applique ça à chaque photo ça
nous donne paraît une série de chiffres
qui sert sûrement à quelque chose pour
débloquer une autre étape du jeu on va
voir ça après le soir-même nella doit
s'occuper de sa mère qui habite loin de
l'endroit indiqué alors elle va demander
à des tweetos d'aller prendre la photo
tellement danger ses followers quoi faut
pas la suivre dallas faut pas suivre
elle reçoit donc pas mal de photos et
points communs dans toutes ces photos
c'est qu'un poteau sur lequel il a
marqué 3 161 on a donc le dernier nom
qui complètent cette série elle envoie
donc la série au numéro elle reçoit un
sms qui lui dit qu'il est incorrect mais
tu n'es pas loin on te laisse une
dernière opportunité réfléchit bien
le coup de pression en publiant la
dernière photo sur un stan et la
s'aperçoit que bahia certaines photos
qui ont été prises de nuit et d'autre
deux jours du coup parce qu'il y avait
une heure imposé par photo comme on l'a
dit et tout ça a été fait de manière à
ce que les photos de nuit forme un f
n'est là elle pense que c'est pas une
coïncidence
et elle veut ajouter le f au code elle
décide de le mettre à la fin du code et
l envoi ca au numéro en question et là
surprise un petit singe rouge choquée
elle va donc râpé le numéro est le
message n'est plus le même qu'avant
à partir de là les énigmes s'enchaînent
et je voulais raconter un peu en
accéléré parce que ça dure vraiment
milan et c'est abusé comme le jeu va
loin et c'est abusé commencé dur
heureusement que tu es là elle a plein
plein de followers sinon elle aurait
jamais pu trouver bon on est là elle va
donc analyser le code de l'image elle va
tomber sur une url en tapant l'url dans
son navigateur ça va l'amener sur un
site celle où il ya un compte à rebours
est en cours est ce que le compte à
rebours s'est déclenchée au moment où
elle est arrivée sur le site où est ce
que il dure depuis que le tout le jeu a
commencé on sait pas et en dessous ce
compte à rebours il ya une indication
entre et la réponse ici quelles réponses
comptable quoi bordel
elle est passée d'une épreuve à une
autre alors elle va rappeler le numéro
et elle a bien fait parce que numéro
maintenant dit autre chose
la première phrase du premier livre ok
parallèlement sfr à qui son compte
facebook et son image de profil et sa
manière ont été remplacés par des images
de singe rouge
on suppose donc que les mecs cada le jeu
sont des [ __ ] de l'akr la première
phrase du premier livre il s'agit en
fait de la première phrase du livre la
genèse qui est la suivante le premier
jour dieu créa le ciel et la terre elle
va leur taper ça sur le site est
apparemment c'était le bon truc à
marquée puisqu'elle va recevoir un mail
dans lequel il ya marqué un code binaire
c'est quoi ces aînés et demain ça
n'arrête plus et l'objet du mail et un
peu crépus parce qu'il dit assurent toi
d'avoir ta webcam allumée pendant que tu
lis mail est-ce que tu as accès marie
cap connard de bakker la webcam donne
hélas mais alors à clignoter
c'est un peu flippant elle dit qu'elle
redémarre son mac ça continue à
clignoter et des tweets osons dire année
là que le code binaire qu'il ya dans le
mail quand le traduit ça donne un lien
vimeo petit problème la vidéo vimeo elle
est en privé et il faut un code pour
pouvoir la voir
oui on peut faire sa survie mais les
gens vont donc très vite comprendre que
les clignotements de la webcam donné là
c'est un second code morse qui lorsque
l'on traduit nous donne le code qui
permet d'accéder à la vidéo vimeo ça va
loin bordel mon cerveau l'eyepet moi le
téléphone je le refus dans le par je
m'en bats les couilles
en tout cas sa théorie était bonne
puisque elle a pu accéder à la vidéo
vimeo et
elle aurait préféré ne pas y accéder du
tout d'ailleurs
creepy en fait ce jeu il n'est pas du
tout ça en fait un mec avec un masque de
singe s'est introduit chez n'est là et
ça merde c'est clairement le pire truc
qui peut t'arriver en trouver une vidéo
où c'est un mec qui est chez toi qui te
filme tudors et a jamais su que c'était
arrivé étude des coûts et tu te sens
très très mal
à la fin de la vidéo on voit très
clairement le mec retirer la coque du
téléphone donné là et glisser un petit
papier donc mais là elle va récupérer ce
petit papier elles valent coûté et il
dit un truc pas très cool puisqu'ils dit
nous la tenons nous là ramèneront ici en
fonction de toi bien seul ne dit pas où
et quand et à la suite de cette phrase
et a marqué une adresse en là on
commence à toucher à la fin ça parents
kidnapping donc c'est chaud les
réactions humaines plutôt que d'aller
voir la police et de leur dire ce qui se
passe ta peur que ça met en péril ton
proche donc tu fais ce que les méchants
il dit voilà tu vas au rendez vous c'est
ce que nadal va faire et elle va en
arrivant sur place prendre des vidéos de
ce qu'elle voit pas ce que c'est très
chaud loup
bah oui quelle bonne idée ban dans le
coffre n'est la havane si je t'en prie
m'énerve là quand les gens ils sont
stupides là c'est comme dans les films
sont mineurs elle va tout et que la
voiture a fait un arrêt cas quelqu'un
d'autre qui est monté dedans mais elle
sait pas qui quand comment ni où ils
vont les kidnappeurs donné l'avons alors
la laisser dans un garage et se barrer
toute une photo elle nous dit bon je
sais pas où je suis mon laissez là y'a
personne ne sait pas quoi [ __ ]
elle va errer dans ce parking moisi
complètement vide et elle va trouver un
ascenseur et dans cet ascenseur il ya
juste un seul but pendant que
l'ascenseur monte sur l'écran on voit le
logo singes rouge qui apparaît elle est
peut être au coeur du gang qui gère tout
ça depuis le début n'est pas de la
censure souvenez la descend et elle
filme tout de suite ce qu'elle voit et
c'est [ __ ] de creepy ces gens vraiment
un décor de film d'horreur tu as
vraiment je pas envie d'être là de toute
ta vie est là elle tombe sur un
ordinateur et coupe le son de la jungle
avec un code à taper était ce un singe
rouge et a un qui marche bien twitter
qui lui sauve la vie il à shazam la
bande son de la vidéo et apparemment
c'est un titre interprété par red
mountain de bingo c'est le bon code est
ce qu'on arrive enfin à la fin et on va
savoir pourquoi c'est quoi ce jeu et qui
sont ces gens un dossier qui porte le
nom donné la peine henning puis tu n' ya
pas de ningde dans l'est la tweet que
d'après ce qu'elle vient de voir la
fosse marta est le portage c'était juste
des appâts dans le but d'attirer les là
à cet endroit effectivement on s'en rend
compte dans la vidéo qu'elle publie
juste après
[Musique]
est ce que c'est la sirène qui marque la
fin de toutes les digues est ce qu on a
enfin la clé qui va lui citer le mystère
pendant peu plus nous nail art manque de
réseau va nous donner de nouvelles comme
elle peut elle va nous dire qu'elle a
fui les meubles qu'elle est juste à côté
que la larme continue de sonner mais que
des fois elle s'arrête pendant quelques
secondes et que pendant ces quelques
secondes elle récupère du réseau à ce
moment là uniquement elle peut nous
prévenir de ce qui s'est passé elle
tombe sur une sorte de grosse base lui a
des antennes comme un gros complexe
télécoms a publié
du coup elle va appeler au moment où il
ya du réseau le [ __ ] de numéros alors
que devrait appeler la police totalement
je suis d'accord et le numéro lui dit
elle va alors comprendre que ce qu'ils
attendent d'elle c'est que elles
rétablissent signale ce qu'elle nous a
pas dit ses petites manies ne sais que
c'est un programme e
du coup elle s'y connaît bien en
informatique elle va donc retourner dans
l'immeuble ou pc pour essayer de
rétablir sur [ __ ] tina et kun a enfin
des réponses une fois dans le pc elle
résout le problème est là on n'a plus de
nouvelles de della pendant quelque temps
mais quand elle redonne on comprend
après avoir réussi à réparer le signal
les lumières sont allumées la lame s'est
arrêtée la couverture réseau a été
complètement rétablie donc née là a
compris que le jeu était terminée elle a
aussi compris qu'elle a été choisie
parce que c'était une candidate parfaite
et il le savait parce qu'elles avaient
partagé toutes les infos pour qu'il le
sache sur ces réseaux sociaux comme tout
le monde le fait elle comprend ainsi que
c'est pas la seule à avoir vécu ce
truc-là ya d'autres candidats aussi qui
ont fait toutes ces épreuves
c'était des tests visant à recruter des
gens dans l'organisation raidh monique
et le singe rouge là en gros c'est
carrément une secte qui travaille pour
essayer de rendre internet plus sain
pour que les gens soient moins en danger
face plus gaffe alors donné que leurs
données soient en sécurité etc et leur
manière de recruter étrange met en
évidence le fait qu on partage tous
beaucoup trop d'infos à venir sur
internet et qu'il est très facile de
savoir quasiment tout sur quelqu'un
grâce à internet par exemple il savait
qu'il est là l adorer les énigmes et
mystères il savait que sa mère elle
était très importante pour elle bon sauf
peut être un génie a priori ils savaient
qu'ils allaient réagir est comme ça
quelle compétence elle avait donc a été
fort en développement qu'elle
partagerait tout sur twitter et que tout
le monde la dre relire et ça c'était
pour une manière de savoir si elle était
qualifiée et qu'elle pouvait rejoindre
secteur caraman et participer aux
centaines de milliers d'attaqués
virtuelles qui vont faire sur tous les
serveurs sur lequel sont hébergés les
données
de tous les humains est ma [ __ ] si on
avait su ça les amis c'est la fin du
thread red monkey j'espère que ça vous a
plu n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo si c'est
le cas franchement il est trop bien
foutu ya plein de photos plein de vidéos
y a quand même dit de morale cool c'est
qu'effectivement faut faire attention à
nous donner faut faire attention à ce
qu'on partage sur les réseaux sociaux
veut tout faire gaffe à ce que les gens
peuvent savoir de nous alors qu'ils ne
connaissent même pas dans la vraie vie
que nous on les connaît pas et ça c'est
vrai et on a tous tendance à partager
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de notre vie
privée sur internet globalement et c'est
ça peut être très dangereux je rappelle
celle d'un combat compris tout ça c'est
fictif c'est une fiction qui a été
écrite par n'est là avec aussi quelqu'un
d'autre qu'on connaît bien manuel parles
tu vois qui a écrit le thread soudé
c'est lui c'est mes gars décrit ce
serait d y en a même fait un livre
derrière manuel
bravo c'est génial j'espère qu'elle vous
a plu et puis voilà je dis à bientôt sur
youtube dans une autre vidéo sur twitter
live chaque jeudi de 20 heures à minuit
voilà j'ai lancé l'info à bientôt une
prochaine vidéo au revoir
[Musique]
je